with the requirement to connect to the
internet we need an arrangement or a
setup that automatically assigns us a
public ip address to help us get our
devices connected to the internet
this task is performed by nat that is
also known as network address
translation
hi guys and welcome to yet another
interesting video by simply learn
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel or
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from us
now without further ado
let's begin with the agenda for today's
session
to start with we will look into some
details regarding network address
translation
continuing with knowing what is nat
addresses
different types of nat available in the
network channel
and in the end we will look into some
disadvantages and advantages of applying
nat in a network channel
let's move on with the first heading
what is network address translation
the motif behind implementing
nat is to allow several network devices
to connect to the internet by a single
public address
the nart model is a method to conserve
ip addresses by using a unique address
to represent the whole private
network and the mentioned public ip
address is a globally recognized ip
address to access the internet
let's move on to some more details
regarding network address translation
the task of nat process is to translate
a private ip address in a network
to a globally recognized public ip
address
and vice versa
that is the same process begins from
public ip address to a private ip
address
this task is performed by a router or a
nat firewall
let's move on
the flow of this process is something
similar
like the router configured
acts as an interface between the private
and network and the public network
that means the private network will
communicate with the router when it
wants to access an internet
same is the case for public addresses
too when the public address wants to
communicate with the private network the
router will convert it to a private
network id
and allow us to access the internet
the reason behind applying that process
is to conserve public ip addresses
to be more specific it's ipv4 addresses
and it also provides much better
security to the network
now let's move on to the next topic
nat addresses
there are different types of terms using
that process
more specifically there are some
addresses information that are necessary
to understand the process which takes
place during network translation
we will discuss them one by one
let's take a look at the first address
before we begin
let's take a look at the example
this is a general or any simple form of
nat translation process
we have a private network
a private device a router a public
network
that we can access internet through
the first term that is used is known as
insight local address
this ip address represents the host of
the private network
and this cannot access the internet
directly
unless provided by an isp server
after we have the inside local address
through the private network we share it
with the crowder
when the router receives this private
network id
it converts it to the public network
that is known as
inside global address
this ip address represents the whole
private network
for the outside network
and is used to access the internet for
the private network
now let's move on to the remaining ip
addresses for nat
according to this example now we are
returning from a public network to the
private network please keep that in mind
according to this
the address type next comes up its
outside global address
this ip address represents the outside
network address for the host before nat
process took place
then we have
outside local address
this ip address represents the actual
address representing the host on the
internet after the net process takes
place
now let's move on to the next setting in
the topic
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
types of nat
there are different types of nat
available on the internet or on the
network channel but we will discuss
three
generally used ones
where the first one is known as static
nat
according to static nat process
in the given private network
each device will have
a
particular or a single ip address
publicly
designed to them
that means if you have two devices in
your private network
you will have two different types of
public ip addresses for each of those ip
addresses
that is available in your private
network
due to this property of the static nat
process it is also known as one to one
net
and is mostly used for personal
addresses
for example please take a look at the
diagram below
if we have a single ip address
in a private network
we will have a single public ip address
for the same
again if we have another private ip
address in the private network we will
have
a public ip address for the same
this represents static network
let's move on to the next one
the next type of nat process
is known as dynamic nut
for the dynamic nat process
private network addresses is translated
to public addresses from a pool of
public ip addresses available to the
communication channel
that is
something similar to this
according to the example if we have two
private addresses available in the
network then we have two poll of public
addresses too
out of which we can convert the private
address to a public address
and for example if we have a third
private address and only two possible
public addresses pool then the third
address is dropped
let's take a look
at the diagram for a clarification
this is the pool of public addresses
available for this network
out of which
we converted
192.168.32
to
213.18 0.123 to point 100
now let's move on to the last type of
nut available
this nat is known as port address
translation
in port address translation of nat
the process takes place something
similar like this
all the available private ip addresses
in the private network are converted to
a single
available ip address publicly
recognized
that means if you have five private
networks in your available network
you will have a single public ip address
available to all of them
due to this nature of this process it is
also known as not overload
but
the catches
all the addresses in the private network
available will have different port
number assigned to differentiate between
them
for example 192.168.32.10
is translated to 213.18.123.100.11
where 101 represents the
port number
similarly for the second private network
we have 192.168.32.12
which translates to 213.18.123.100
that is similar with the earlier case
but the change comes over
0.102
that is the port number assigned to the
second private address
now let's take up a small quiz to
refresh all the topics that we read so
far
and the first question is
what does outside local address refer to
in nand
your options are
name of insight source address before
translation
name of destination was before
translation
name of inside host after translation
name of outside destination host after
translation
please read the options very carefully
to answer this
now let's move on to the next question
and the question is
pat address is also termed as
part refers to port address translation
option a static net
option b one to one nat
option c not overload
and option d
not overlapping
you can give your answers in the comment
section
now let's move on to the last heading
for this session that is
advantages and disadvantages of applying
nat in a network channel
let's take a look at the first advantage
of using nut
nat provides privacy and security
measures to the private address
as it converts
a private address to a public address
through which we can prevent our id from
being
hacked
over the internet
let's move on to the next advantage
that process is applied to conserve
approved ip addresses over the network
channel as discussed earlier in the
previous slides
nat process helps to conserve us ipv4
addresses
now let's look into some disadvantages
of applying nat in the network channel
and the first disadvantage is not
translation leads to part delay and
prevent some applications
to lose their access over the network
channel
now let's take a look at the second
disadvantage
according to the nat process router is
the one that translates a private
address to a public address or vice
versa
during this process it does happen to
tamper with the port numbers as we
already discussed
but according to the rules set by the
network channel
router is not usually allowed to hamper
with the port numbers but it has to
because of nat
with this we have reached the end of
this session if you have any questions
regarding the topic you can ask them in
the comments section
thank you for watching
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here